all righty you know we're back everybody
Corridor Digital podcast this is episode
183 we're coming to you from the
corridor digital studio in Los Angeles
California and my little stinky Studio
here in Texas for being here where were
the other trucks going
uh guys what's up what's up what's up
[Laughter]
wow what's amazing just everything yeah
we got Play-Doh we got friends we got
time on our hands and we're alive
everybody else right thanks for joining
us on the corridor cast I've got Jalen
Dean Nick and myself here today
and uh We've the Play-Doh is back for
everyone who played those back it is
Flowing it is circulating
you'll be out the Play-Doh there have
been some real problems but it's back so
don't worry guys
yep soon the homies will be back too
we've bulk ordered homies they're on
their way
yeah yeah
we're gonna have them all only the
wheelchair ones though
for your birthday I'm just gonna get you
like 10 wheelchair homies heck yeah dude
I was uh when I was trying to come up
with the title of that video I got deep
into a homies Rabbit Hole yeah do you
order any for an investment no I didn't
we need homes I was too foolish to put
my investment dollars into homies big
mistake but uh yeah I did go down a few
Google rabbit holes where I was just it
was all coming back to me oh it's a
beautiful thing truly yeah Dean was not
there for that unfortunately but yeah I
have no idea or for homes in general I
think yeah you missed that back then you
were dead back then you were pretty
alive probably wasn't even born yet he's
on pre-order what year is this
yeah
you probably just didn't want
to order uh
I feel like this has been sort of been
like
1998.99 okay I'm 97 so I was alive yeah
yeah you were like you just missed it
you were you needed a quarter you were a
poor baby
um but yeah but Dean is here and
honestly Dean Dean has been fuming about
something in particular for a long time
well yeah for yeah for very long time
very long time months probably yeah I
don't even know when this movie came out
yeah for months but it's it's come up
again because you watched it and you
guys talked about it on the effects are
react and it is oh dude Flash no wait so
we you know Ren Sam and I we did a react
recently and I was bringing the flash I
was bringing a couple scenes and as I
was watching the film I just kept adding
scenes to the list going oh and we got
to talk about this oh my gosh and this
and this and eventually we just pivoted
and made a whole episode about the ball
within the bad category that's how you
know it's bad
it's a funny it's a funny mixed bag
because uh Dean came I think you saw the
premiere didn't you no so I went and saw
the movie by myself
uh just very sad afterwards very feeling
very empty and I came back to the studio
the next day and I think I told you the
entire plot of the movie which any other
movie it would have totally left my
brain yeah but this was a special one
because you as you guys know the PC
Comics fan
and um were you looking forward to the
flash I was looking forward to it by the
way Tom Cruise and a bunch of
celebrities were coming out and they're
like this is one of the best movies ever
really wow yeah Tom Cruise was like this
is Gonna Save theaters did he produce
those who don't know I don't know they
must have paid him or something I don't
know why he said that for those who
don't know Dean is a wealth of knowledge
about uh Comics but even more
particularly DC Comics you know yeah I
spent way too much time on it growing up
I kind of regret I could have been
building other skills dude you could
have spent more time with homies
you know this wasn't just a casual guy
getting a ticket on a Thursday because
you know he doesn't have anything better
to do Dean was genuinely looking forward
to this event yeah dude I picked the
wrong I picked the wrong train you know
so when when I was a child and it was
leaving the station they're like Marvel
DC I was like oh man I love Batman I
love Superman I hopped on it was good
for a while we had Christopher Nolan uh
and then it just really started going
downhill and the Flash felt like
you know the Rock Bottom like the train
came off the rails completely so so you
saw Justice League though like were you
on the Ezra train already were you like
hang on like I think this will you know
the separate the art of the artist yeah
the theatrical Justice League was
is objectively a terrible movie but I
have I had Phantom Menace syndrome
walking out of it where I was like I was
turning to people I was like that was
great right that was awesome Jimenez
syndrome and then I went and saw it a
second time and that was about the third
time I saw it that I was like this is
terrible wait movie but you do you feel
that way about the director's cut as
well no the director's cut is pretty is
pretty good okay it's like a really
solid movie but the theatrical cut
is awful
and actually particularly because it
cuts out so much of the
good character moments that are in the
director's cut because they're trying to
get it down to length and so it mostly
becomes about the plot which is super
generic even in the director's cut but
um yeah there's just a lot of weird
additions to it but anyway else isn't
about Justice League I mean I'm gonna
say though I don't really take the
superhero movies too much like you know
every once in a while they'll get to me
but Justice League was good particularly
I liked the flash sequence like I'm like
wait like which did you watch this
action yeah yeah sorry I'm talking about
the Snyder cut again the good part but
so I liked what they did with it I
thought it was cool yeah the rescue
through the glass with the little oh so
sad and then you see the quality of the
VFX too and yeah you know I didn't I
don't really follow Ezra Miller drama so
I I separated him I had no I had no
premonitions about that when they shot
that movie and when that movie was
released there was nothing Ezra Miller
hadn't done anything crazy yet I think
he had there was one video of him like
choke slamming a girl but wasn't crazy
he hadn't done anything crazy yet except
the one video of him it was out of
nowhere and then it kind of went away it
was like oh that was really weird
interesting that's right weird huh what
a weird thing to do okay anyway
but no I agree the the Zack Snyder just
leave I really enjoyed and
um and in particular I liked I liked
Ezra Miller in that movie because he's
kind of the comic relief and because
everything's you know his actionary
keeps it very like serious dim and
serious and uh he was kind of the one
bolt of light in that and I was excited
for the flash I was and I'd seen
interviews with him and it seemed like
he really understood what is interesting
about the character which is like it's
he's kind of like a a physics like
science character like you know oh he
runs fast but when you actually go into
what that suggests for a character it's
like he can vibrate at you know these
speeds to like move his molecules
through things he can travel through
time such a sick Power by the way yeah
that's a really cool let me just vibrate
yeah so wait so he can travel through
time yes yeah it and he can travel
through universes we're all traveling
through time but we don't choose the way
he can choose the direct travel yeah
okay well and not specifically but
also he can travel through universes
which you know is probably the most
depressing part about this film and
we'll get to that but yeah I feel like
do they do any of that and sorry well
yeah wait for it because okay let me
continue to set up yeah yeah flash is
like as a character his place in the
Justice League and in the DC Universe
he's kind of like Spider-Man a little
bit he's like a little more relatable
than like Batman or Superman he's just
like a guy working his job and then he
becomes a superhero and uh so yeah I was
I was excited for this movie because of
everything that was built up and then I
sat down to watch it and Jordan you can
follow along with me as well because
you've seen it too there's a scene in
the beginning of the movie with some
babies I mean we're talking the
beginning like this is the opening
season start a tone setter this is the
tone Setter yeah for sure and and and
Jordan and I were talking about this
it's a the tone they're going for is a
bit of like Looney Tunes yeah which is
really an odd choice for like a
emotionally you know driven superhero
movie but they were going for like wacky
Looney Tunes but I don't know how many
people knew that because when I sat down
to watch it I had no inkling or
indication that it was going to be
Looney Tunes but as I was watching it I
was just like oh this is
super goofy silly and I didn't expect
that because tonally what I've seen from
DC in the past and I'm not like I don't
go and watch all the movies but what
I've seen is a very serious somber tone
and they take it more seriously than
Marvel does but this was like completely
an inversion in approach it was almost
took me off guard it made like Marvel
movies look more like serious the
serious one because it was like
the opening scene felt like a like a bad
Saturday morning cartoon
where so for you guys you haven't seen
it there's a a sequence where Barry is
like there's a hospital that's
collapsing and he looks up and then at
the top floor they show there's a room
full of like 20 babies and the building
starts tipping over and the babies come
screening out of the building through
through the windows and now they're
shout these babies are showering down
and he has to run up the building and
then save them in slow motion which was
a great line objectively as a pun
Enthusiast to go it's a baby shower
[Music]
or Jake come on Oh I pushed that out
come on I'm keeping that with me that
scar is staying with me that's painful
but immediately like that scene starts
and you know you guys will talk about it
on react the effects are objectively
terrible dude and really the director
came out and was like
and he was he basically just said like
we were shooting for that like it was
supposed to feel weird yeah the the
effect so there's a lot of effects that
look cool
just to be honest about it but the
problem is where your eye is drawn the
things that pull you as a viewer all of
those things are the things that are
flawed and like of course the most major
thing is people right you can't
you like it's very very difficult we
just did this all the things you're
supposed to look at are bad yeah yeah
because all the disruptive elements like
the the vibe is sick and it's great
destruction work but your eye isn't
drawn to the destruction it's drawn to
the falling babies and the falling
babies you know they're they're far from
perfect and since that's what you're
looking at you're immediately no longer
feeling any sort of sense of danger or
care for these babies or the solution
they're CG Gumby guys yeah they're sons
of babies literally they probably have
about 16 vertices on that match of each
baby I kid you not dude you can see
basically the sharp corners on those on
the freaking swaddle what's it called
the clothy wrap around a baby or
whatever so like and they're all
swaddled for like obviously because
the VFX artists just didn't have enough
freaking what machine power to like
render out a flailing baby so they just
swaddle them in some like low poly mesh
cloth and just Chuck them out a window I
think it only shows it all comes down to
time it does smoothies because the
amount of craziness surrounding this
film so yeah so the director you
mentioned he's how many directors has he
gone through oh it's gone four God yeah
for so many directors like this movie's
been in in uh
production for or development for like
15 years yeah it was for it was first
announced I believe
in 2014 was it or 20 2018 was the
initial release date that they wanted to
aim for and I think it was supposed to
be Rick famayiwa who did
um dope which is a great movie it's a
great movie yeah uh but he dropped out
due to creative differences with who
with the yeah with DC yeah yeah um and
he's doing Star Wars stuff now so he
read the movie scene he's like nope so I
went through a bunch of directors after
that I can't really remember them all
but it ended up with uh Andy machete who
did it the it movies which I loved I
loved the movie but also they and it
works for a horror movie but like the
the tone is very similarious man it's a
little bit self-aware and like
um it's like it's a little bit of
self-parity it's a little bit of winking
at the audience and going like this is
dumb you know and like you you watch it
too and there's like a little bit of
that from like Bill hader's character
and um so with this movie Jumping right
in right to the first scene having it be
these like the it's like the director
went what is the dumbest thing a
superhero could do it's like oh he's not
just gonna save a baby he's Gonna Save
like 20 babies and they're all falling
out of a building and as the scene was
going I was like oh they don't care
they don't like this is like a joke to
them and I'm sitting there with my
popcorn I like deeply love these
characters and you just I'm just sitting
there like oh man they don't care at all
and then so that's it
and you're sitting there alone having to
spend forty dollars to be there total
yeah go in wow they already have your
money and now they're just taunting you
yeah
and then after that they go straight to
a Chase sequence or it's like intercut
with a Chase sequence with Ben Affleck's
Batman which Ben Affleck
you know God rested
so I feel so bad for him because he
signed up for this first movie Batman v
Superman which was like a really dark
take on Batman very intense take on
Batman I think that's why he agreed to
it but he probably signed like a
long-term contract for these movies and
the tone has changed so much that he's
in this movie in the full like blue
Batman costume it's broad daylight and
he's doing like the hands on hips like
hey kids you know good job saving the
day like that kind of stuff and I'm like
this poor guy
and the suit looks so I mean dude I
could go so like the suit looks so bad
and then they have gal gadoshop again to
like deliver some wooden lines is it a
CG suit
everything's pretty much CG there's like
one close-up and we've talked about this
yes and again going back to Batman v
Superman they have this like very
intricately designed cowl which is a
different like design aesthetic from the
other Batman movies and it's like very
sculpted and carved but it looks great
at night but when they bring him out in
broad daylight you could just see the
latex and like how it's pinching his
face and like Ben Affleck just looks
like he's he's shoved into this mask and
he's just like
get the mask squeezer yeah we're about
to roll we got some acne freaking face
covers
sorry Ben I know you haven't been in
real suit for a while I think that's the
only shot of Ben Affleck in the movie
and there are scenes that Ben Affleck is
just Bruce Wayne in but like him in the
Batman costume that's got to be the only
shot of him that's actually him because
all the other shots are like him on a
motorcycle or behind him and they
probably just had a stuffed man well
James Gunn is on record here as he's
what he's this isn't he like the CEO of
DC he's the head of DC Studios now yeah
so I I was reading an interview from him
and he was saying he wants all of these
to have a different tonality like you
know you have the really gritty series
you have the super jokey wacky and
obviously like Guardians of the Galaxy I
think he Nails it it does really good
um but yeah this was this was so goofy
and out of left field that it it shocked
me yeah you want to keep it consistent
with
is that they came out of the gate with
Man of Steel
Man of Steel is kind of its own thing
but right after that they the money for
Man of Steel wasn't quite what they were
expecting and they immediately started
taking what Zack Snyder wanted to do
with these movies which was to do a kind
of his own thing like a Dark Twisted
take on these characters that would kind
of end up
with them as the heroes you know
but to kind of go through that whole Arc
but they immediately started course
correcting and then Batman v Superman
got terrible reviews and that's why the
theatrical cut of Justice League
happened is because they were like make
it funny like Marvel but it's kind of
smashed together with Zack Snyder's yeah
aesthetic which is just such an uncanny
thing well that's I mean if you want a
way to kill any creative project it's
open the kitchen doors and introduce
hundreds of cooks yeah who have probably
never cooked anything before you know or
at least not creatively and it's like
all these notes the fact that you go
through four directors you go through
like three or four iterations of the
script you push the date three or four
times it's like it must have just been
absolute chaos in the kitchen of all
these conflicting thoughts and people
wanting to have their stamp left on it
you know that was my idea all this stuff
and then the director is just trying to
Shield an original Creative Vision and
keep track of it through the course of a
feature it's an nightmare I guess I
shouldn't blame him after the first
director though walks off the project
after that it's just about how do we not
burn more money yeah so it's like
imagine being hired as what the fourth
director and you're like oh my job is
literally just to keep this thing
somewhat on the rails yeah and make sure
that these eight CG babies got
composited and so do you have a day you
have a day a match so imagine how much
money they burn through in the however
many years of production and then Ezra
Miller has a complete mental breakdown I
don't think they were even they might
have been fully they weren't done
production
when Ezra Miller had their like complete
you know throwing chairs at people
kidnapped
kidnapping people uh it was I don't know
what he did but that sounds about right
all I heard that people and he was
leaving guns out all over the place
where when that kids could basically
yeah there was a bag of guns he's just
leaving them out just there was a
compound at one point which it tells you
something and the the fact that Ezra is
brought out onto the red carpet for this
movie is just so telling of how much
money was put into it because
they they there was a point where people
were like you're gonna cancel this movie
right yeah alleged kidnapping by the way
alleged right kidnapping it's a blanket
term you know yeah it could be lots of
things but the kid was napping what was
I supposed to do so yeah there's just
it's it's really I mean this movie and
Justice League are two of the most
interesting stories of
like a film's production in history like
the history of Cinema it's like Justice
League you have you know Zack Snyder his
family lost their their daughter and he
had to drop it out of production and
then they put Josh Whedon on it this
movie you have yeah years of production
and then Ezra Miller loses his mind yeah
um and it turned out in uh piece of crap
well I'll say this I will say this Dean
came back and and just roasted it to
Pieces when I first heard about it uh
and obviously in preparation for this I
wanted to watch the whole thing and have
the context of it and I will say it was
better than I expected I I laughed a few
times yeah I was smiling a little bit
like I had a good time some of the
visual effects were really good yeah
some of them were were very noticeable
and bad
um but overall it was a better
experience than I expected going in that
said I have no like Affinity or or like
you know connection to these characters
I had some friends who were like oh I
was fine I I think the thing about it
for me is not that it's like a terrible
story it's just a completely
generic serviceable story that is only
like it the plot points only exist to
get another character in from like uh
here he is which of course is summed up
perfectly I think before we get to the
freaking cameos
it was awful remember but let me so no
just to get to get you up to speed they
they send them back in time the whole
movie the craziest part about the movie
is that it's not just one Ezra Miller
it's two Ezra Miller's he's meeting
himself from Another Universe and the
whole movie is two Ezra Miller's on
screen yeah another universe so you're
saying they brought in a Multiverse yeah
so so the idea is that the Flash
uh realizes that he can uh uh move
through Time by running really fast you
know going faster than the speed of
light yeah he breaks so he you know his
his kind of core trauma like Batman is
that his his he had a parent die when
he's young it was his mom and she was
murdered they don't know why so he's
going back in time to try to you know
stop her from being killed
and it's the butterfly effect he goes
back and changes one thing to make sure
that that doesn't happen and he comes
back to the present and he realizes
the you know the Future Has Changed but
they make it so he's actually in a new
branching timeline yeah that is a
different Multiverse or Universe instead
of like just the future branching off
and changing Yeah by changing one thing
you've shifted the past and the future
so people new people are different
people now yeah which is yeah it totally
makes sense
Back to the Future set the cannon for
all time travel movies no but it's work
it's kind of worse than Back to the
Future because I know like I'm saying if
they if you don't follow the Back to the
Future logic oh I see yeah no you have
to you have to otherwise it doesn't make
any sense and in this case it doesn't
make any sense because it's just an
excuse for them to go like we Michael
Keaton's here now yeah that's it just
Michael Keaton is here now and it's so
it turns out Batman yeah it's Michael
Keaton's Batman from the 89. it's from
there they even went further back Jake
they even went further back
in there oh yeah yeah that's later
that's later okay but so Keaton is
uh it's his character from the 89 Batman
so it's not just like he's in this as
Batman it's the character from those two
movies and they come they find him he's
like an old guy
yes from the 89 Batman has replaced Ben
Affleck and but now this Bruce Wayne is
older as well he's older because they
didn't want to do visual effects on
Michael Keaton yeah and it like yeah
they could have totally done that but
it's a universe where he was old all the
time yeah man
like 20 years ago which makes and he
looks like a different human being it
takes no question
it's really fast now okay
a nerdy Divergence into the comics this
is based on a comic book called
Flashpoint which is a very classic comic
book and interestingly the flashpoint
comic was also meant as a way to reboot
DC Comics just in the same way that this
movie's meant to reboot the DC Cinematic
Universe that's the thing you're saying
this like it's a merit like it's meant
to reboot this and it's like so that's a
corporate business decision no that's
what I mean they are shoving down our
throat as as art consumers and saying
don't you guys care about this we're
gonna reboot this universe it's like so
you're just coming out in the open
you're saying you want to mine our
wallets for the next 10 years with this
crap but so like like in the comics the
reason they have to do that is because
there's like 75 years of these
characters and their interactions with
each other and sometimes they just have
to go guys we need to allow new people
to be able to read these comic books
we're starting over Batman's Batman just
became Batman Superman just became
Superman so they have to like hit a
reset and so they hit that every like 20
years or something so 500 they do a
Multiverse and bring it all together for
a big party and then they reset yeah
exactly but so it's crazy how the DC
movies manage to reach the same level of
convolutedness in like five years just
by the movies being poorly yeah directed
and like guided
um but so in the comics Barry goes back
in time and instead of it being just a
random dude that he's never met it's
it's Bruce Wayne's father is now Batman
and his mom and Bruce Wayne's mom is now
the Joker because because Bruce Wayne
died as a kid's mom is the Joker yeah
[__] off
actually I think it's kind of does it
make any sense at all no so now we're
playing house with other Superheroes
Batman and Joker
um
they're like brothers
but it's no so it's not just a fan
Theory isn't that actually in Canada are
they actually brothers no they're not
Brothers what are you talking about are
you sure I heard a strong Theory two
brothers yeah but you keep going with
this stuff there's Jacob it's a
Multiverse and one Multiverse that's
your truth this is the convoluted thing
is in comics everything has happened in
comics everybody's died at least three
times gotcha you know X Y and Z but so
in the comics all I'm trying to say with
the flashpoint comic is that it's people
that Barry knows so like Wonder Woman
and Aquaman are now at War like the
atlantians and the amazonians are at War
so there's a whole War happening on
earth like there's all this crazy stuff
happening and in the movie it's just hey
here's Michael Keaton
and zod's coming back you guys
you remember Zod yeah there's some
suggestion guys
and Joker are brothers
but it's never been by Jake Watson
conspiracy he's down the rabbit hole
tinfoil bat cow alone have you seen
Joker
the dark one right in Phoenix yeah in
the walking Phoenix movie yeah yeah they
suggest that but that's just that movie
that I don't remember yeah but isn't
that thing isn't that part of the
Multiverse man yeah that's a Multiverse
everything's possible there is
definitely a universe where Joker and
our brothers yeah I kind of like this
Multiverse I could just say whatever I
want Batman is a brother with his foot
yeah
those are my favorite branches and his
other foot yeah is Flash dude that looks
sick I want to watch that
what the hell is going on no she's not
played by Batman's mom like his mom
became the Joker it's the same thing
okay he's Batman is Batman is Bruce
Wayne is Batman Okay
Joker it's not Batman
Jake I don't touch Jake's Batman
Jake you can I have your Batman okay
okay don't you start saying my truth
this is just don't get into the mic that
much I will absolutely lose this
thing okay just Truth Truth by its very
definition is not subjective to the
individual no I'm sorry Jake but those
numbers are doing it all the writers are
saying but it's my truth no there's a
Multiverse Dean's truth is the Batman's
mom is the Joker okay that's Dean's
truth we have to respect the point in
the story in the comics is that by by
Barry saving his mom he ruins or he
changes all these things and now
Batman's world is upside down you know
and Bruce is dead I get it get it but
anyway so you know what the well I don't
I shouldn't spend this much time taking
all the divs point is
things go terribly
uh Barry is like I shouldn't have done
this not another thing I do can help
because that's a really empowering
superhero story is that why
Michael Keaton Batman dies this new
supergirl character dies and bears
likely it's very like [__] I guess I
couldn't help and he leaves this
universe he's like [__] whoops and then
the other beers and tatters
and just leaves it in absolute tatters
and the berry who's from that universe
is like no no dude you can't do this
like my entire planet's gonna die and
he's like it's just [__] happens man
that's like his that's what you made the
characters know that the stakes have
been lowered by this yeah even the
characters are self-aware and I I get
the point they're trying to make it's
like the the point they're trying to
make is like he shouldn't try to go back
and change the past because that trauma
defined him and made him a superhero and
that they kind of way they own in that
point is that this Berry the other Berry
from the other world is like no no I'm
gonna fix this and he keeps going in
this infinite Loop where he's like he
keeps coming back and he's got like more
shards in him from being in this battle
and he like can't fix it but he's like
no no one more time
and then
a new a third flat a third Ezra Miller
so there's three Ezra Miller's in this
movie now he comes back or he enters the
picture and he's like a thousand years
old wait dude are the babies all Ezra
Millers
years old I think they dude they're all
Jokers man he saved all the other
flashes in the uniform right there why
did he also not age
uh I did that that was old flash yeah
he's like really old but he said he's
been doing this for like eons yeah so
it's basically he's the older version of
this other flash who's been trying to
fix it for two minutes on screen so it's
really not that impactful and then he
comes and he's like I'm gonna I figured
it out I have to kill you or something
something dumb and then
um okay that was in the script just
something like a filler I don't know and
then I have to kill you dot dot dot
something dumb something dumb
they kill him or something exterior it
doesn't matter
your days something dumb so I forgot to
mention it
babies something dumb I forgot to
mention the the universe or like the way
they present time travel is like you
know like a Zoe Trope like the kind of
revolving
zoetrope kind of thing is like
that's how they present time travel is
all of Barry's memories are like a Zoe
Trope around him and he's in this little
conceptually very cool yes I agree
visually not very well executed because
it's weird uncanny CG people Jake this
and this is the biggest issue like they
actually try to visualize that yeah he's
running on a trip like basically a
treadmill in the middle that can be done
these days like that seems like one of
the like more down-to-earth the effects
oh yeah I mean this is the thing it was
like visually very complex and it was
like the flash at the center of the Zoe
Trope and you know they had uh all the
different characters and all the
different possibilities like being
visualized and there was a CG camera
kind of floating through it and showing
you you know uh Henry Cavill Superman
and all these other people but the
problem is they didn't use any
photography of these actors yeah they
may just leave them
they know they they use Digi doubles but
the problem is again it's like they're
playing so close with the camera to
these characters that we know so well
you have to hit that High Mark that we
expect otherwise yeah it falls into
uncanny valley and it's not just that it
like barely didn't make it out of
uncanny valley it was deep in the
trenches like Sam kept making the joke
that it's like Polar Express you look at
you go what is that no is that supposed
to be Henry Cavill and so the biggest
insult you're talking about characters
we know and love right
so this sphere of his zoatrope you see
other spheres appearing and and I was
like at this point I was like depressed
this is when the multiverses are
colliding yeah there was everything's
falling to people only Cameo at this
point has been Michael Keaton's Batman
and then Michael Shannon as General Zod
from the Man of Steel movie uh but
they're like characters in the film so
that's that's cool right that's like
it's storytelling
these spheres enter and I'm like [__]
they're about to do everybody's here you
know and so I'm thinking
at that point I get maybe a little bit
of lift because I'm like well I'm just
gonna who's here who's gonna show up the
bus is getting ready Jake no the first
guy is your favorite hero no okay give
me again I thought and I thought Wonder
Woman was bad where she like travels
back in time six different freaking
times with Chris Pine and you're like
guys just give me like
like just be straight with this like
it's like I don't understand why this
movie needs to be 45 minutes of just
them traveling to different places
this is all your favorite characters you
know well Dean real quick if I can just
cut in here because I think like again
I'm not I'm not a big superhero movie
guy but I remember going to end game and
when when the characters
appeared it was earned and people got
excited and they were cheering in the
theater yeah I remember I was there it
was super exciting it's like oh he's
here oh he's here they have a purpose
they're coming to Aid there there's a
reason to save the day and we felt like
we earned it because we watched all the
movies leading up to it was spectacular
it felt like over DC headquarters
they're like how do we do this well
because in the story like in the
literally in the script with the
binoculars
how do we get there
yeah and I forgot about the they forgot
about the earning it part and they're
like oh just sure just show them other
people but yeah that's the problem it's
like it happens it happens at the same
point in the story as end game right so
it's like we're at the very you know
bottom of the you know like the cards
are down like this is bad but the
difference here is that the unit this is
like these characters are coming at us
they are a threat because they're
crashing into our universe and like
they're like gonna destroy our universe
by crashing into us and so it's like Get
Away whereas the the heroes showing up
in Avengers it's like they're here to
save the day these characters are like
no no go away we don't want you here so
but you think got here it doesn't matter
you gotta get out of here now remember
me it's like shut up go
but you'd think at least the least they
could do for all of my pain in watching
this like Diarrhea of a movie is to show
me like here's Christian Bale yeah like
if you have diarrhea you hope there's
gonna be some chunks you know like you
hope there's gonna be something there to
hold on that's the worst metaphor
[Laughter]
is at least 25 30 feet away but like at
least so it and also it's a Flash movie
so there's a Flash TV show that's been
on for like 10 years show me that guy
yeah you know I liked that show for two
seasons
um uh but so instead Jake
we get wait for it
the 1940s George Reeves Superman shows
up
I know you're waiting for that one I
know you were waiting dude yes
Christopher no no no George Reeves wait
what is played Superman in the 40s
series
is that his brother
totally separate but they just used it
they used um someone from the crew I
think I'm serious oh yeah is the scan
look at George Reeves no I just did
there's no imagery of him that has color
yeah no it's black and white this planet
show this [__] planet or whatever
shows up and it's a black and white guy
like and it's not a guy it's a CG model
yeah it looks like he just rolled off
the boat from World War II did this
Superman
during the war I'm pretty sure bro like
this guy's straight out of Germany oh I
was mixing it with the other black and
white guy
oh there you so there is and that guy's
not even a movie character that's I'm
pretty sure that's
um the original Flash from the comics
I'm I'm spacing on his name for some
reason so we see oh Jay Garrick Jay
Garrick in the comics is the original
flash but they they scanned some guy
from the crew yeah just some I think to
be that guy is that true or yeah I think
I read that I read that before the react
I think he was just some guy excuse me
that's even worse it's just some guy I
think I didn't even know that I mean
dude there's like four guys who look
like this just down the street like hey
we gotta get it we got a guy in here we
just need we need a body hey just come
over here
you have to break Dean Spirit even more
oh yeah it was actually just some guy
it's just some [__] guy yeah
get ready here he comes and some guy
we grabbed a random guy on the crew and
tossed it right there okay they had
black panther okay they had who can we
have who can we have some guy hey
hey Jeff come over here man
dude
1940 Superman and some guy yeah you
remember that guy [__] guy
called can you imagine if they they
bring back Captain America and it's just
some guy
we had some guys approved in the credits
of just some guy I can't imagine it
actually I can yes no because the thing
is that character so that because
they're trying to say that like in the
Georgian Superman Universe there's also
a Flash and he's the original Flash and
Jay Carrick in the comics has a very
iconic look he's got like this Tin Can
helmet on yeah it's an old school and
but so there there was I don't think
there was ever a show with that
character so they're just like it
doesn't matter it's just a guy he's
running he's he was also in the Cyclone
or the zootopia whatever it's called
zootopia I'm sure they were thinking
that one was gonna get a real Comic-Con
Buzz so it's like World War One flash
but it like
like George like the character doesn't
even he barely moves like the cape moves
and he's just standing there and then
they're like all right on the next one
and you're like what yeah you're like
okay you enjoy him wait until his next
planet comes and all right you were you
were right Jake it's the other Reeves
it's Christopher Superman but
Christopher Reeves is dead so it's a CG
model very uncanny super very very
uncanny and then dude just up for the
cherry on top you remember the
1977 or whatever Super Girl movie yeah
no yeah no one else does and she walks
up next to him
how is that in the theater did everyone
clap was it silent yeah
just one guy's like
yeah
they did it so he's like who's that
you missed also but you did Miss
um a good Cameo when it flew by Batman
do you remember Batman oh was that did
they have the Adam West they had the
Adam West Batman oh okay yeah I mean he
wasn't doing anything he was just there
yeah so let me get the box from the show
dude they have like clips from the show
and it's like there he is you remember
this one and then they keep moving on so
there's literally so let me just paint a
picture there's a moment at the end of
the film where flash has to confront all
these different versions of himself and
he's running so hard through these like
possible universes he knows to encounter
he's standing he's just standing
standing he's standing there look don't
even get me started on his little like
it's like they've ruined it's whatever
they've ruined the timeline or something
and all the universes are crashing
together yeah and Visually imagine that
it you're if you're the flash you're at
the center of this big sphere and
there's like the roof got ripped off
basically and you're looking outside of
the roof and there's other big spheres
with these other characters in them just
standing just standing looking back
essentially turns it all into a big snow
globe like it's like what this universe
one snow globe
different color it doesn't make any
sense because where is Superman standing
that he's seeing this happen it looks
like Christopher Reeves is on the edge
of this roof like looking out he's just
waving but it's like okay flash is in
like
and also it doesn't make any sense
because it's flash like actively
vibrating through time while he's
standing there like is he actively in
this place or did he end up in this like
how does it anyway what it doesn't
nothing matters anymore no yeah but that
wasn't the biggest reveal of all okay so
it keeps going yeah there's the next one
we get into the Mountaintop there's two
more
um this one is is
it really broke me it really broke me oh
because buddy at least at the very least
these other characters they're from
films they're from media that you've
watched and enjoyed the stories so like
you know when you watch Spider-Man no
way home when Peter Parker from The
Tobey Maguire you know the Toby wire
Peter Parker when he shows up
there's you know there he has his own
arc in that film I guess but the main
thing is you're like oh my God it's the
character I love from this thing that I
enjoyed
the same is true of these characters now
we go to this next character
and you see a giant spider shooting
lasers out of its mouth or something
this was the biggest reveal of the
entire section it was like it was like
they were almost being like [__]
Christopher Reeves yeah everyone else is
you're you've been waiting for this guy
you've earned this so the and then you
see another Superman with long hair long
beautiful flowing hair he lasers The
Spider and kills it and then the sort of
the light shifts over him and he turns
around
and it's Nicholas Cage Superman
[Music]
you might be wondering I don't remember
a Superman movie with Nicholas Cage it's
because it was never made it's because
this Tim Burton was going to make a
Superman movie and Nicholas Cage was
going to be Superman in that movie
because Nicholas Cage is like a massive
Superman fan but the movie got canceled
like really early in production like
nothing was filmed there was like a one
screen test picture which is a very has
become like a meme like that picture of
Nicholas Cage or Superman that's kind of
become a meme
and so not only is this not a character
from this film like he doesn't have his
own internal story in this film
it's not even a character from other
media this isn't a joke it's a character
it's a meme
you're being serious right now no and
it's so like this is the member this is
the rotten dried member bear you find
under the counter on the floor and
you're like oh I remember that from like
eight years ago when I made freaking
member berries smoothie and dropped down
when I read that article on IGN about
how Nicolas Cage was almost Superman
like yeah and Jake and the worst part
like maybe it's like their Pinnacle
moment of church that's the big but Jake
but Jake it wasn't even him it was a
digital Nicholas Cage that was so deep
in The Uncanny Valley they didn't even
give you the real guy it didn't even
look like that Nick Cage it didn't even
really look like I feel like I'm having
a bad drug trip right now yes I do too I
didn't think I felt watching this movie
can you imagine if if I speak if I go
back in time if I pull a Flash and I
pull Dean aside and I go you're gonna
spend two hours leading up to a reveal
of Polar Express Nicholas Cage Superman
do you still want to go inside well and
dude so there's a moment when I saw
Batman v Superman in the theaters
there's a moment in Batman v Superman
where Ezra Miller as the flash
appears from like running back in time
he appears to Bruce Wayne and he's like
you have to save him like Lois is the
key and like you're like oh my God I was
literally hyperventilating because that
was the first movie where they had DC
characters together on screen uh where
like Superman was with Batman all that
stuff so I was that movie was like that
was really my Phantom Menace I guess at
the end of the day because I was like I
leaned over my friend I was like this is
the best movie I've ever seen in my life
and the moment with flash I was like the
possibilities right all of these story
lines were like flash comes back from
the future and you know you're gonna
have different versions these characters
my imagination was running you know and
like you said
the theme of this movie at the end of
the day is like don't have hope for
anything yeah nothing can change
um
right it's like if I could just go back
and give you the message of the film
yeah then when you went in to go see it
it wouldn't hurt as bad you can't change
the past so so that's Jake that's the
big reveal is is Nicholas Cage Superman
and then so Barry comes back to the
present we got one more reveal for you
he comes back to the present and
he let his mom die so great success for
the hero is he let his mother die yeah
good job but he helped he at least
helped his dad get out of uh Being
Framed for a murder so because the court
case was that was like a framing device
at the beginning of the movie so he got
his dad out of jail you know and so he's
walking out of the courthouse and he
gets a call from Bruce Wayne
and already I'm like who's it gonna be I
was thinking like because the thing is
Michael Keaton Batman dies in this movie
and like so unlike him but first of all
you're like Ben Affleck because
apparently Ben Affleck's dad is actually
Batman but you know it you could like
maybe it is Michael Keaton Batman and
then it would kind of help bring home
that point of like no Barry actually was
at actual Barry was able to change
the future right he can't change the
past but he can change the future so he
could have like you know Michael Keaton
could be alive in this new timeline or
something so I'm like oh cool Michael
Keaton's going to be here and then they
can do I don't know they could do like a
Batman Beyond movie where Michael
Keaton's the old I'm starting to like
I'm starting to have hope again which is
stupid that's stupid for being to have
hope again with these DC movies
and then
um
car rolls up
it's like oh Bruce Wayne's here all the
Press runs up which is first of all like
why would Bruce Wayne be at this random
court case in a different city that's
super suspicious and who gets out of the
car Jake
who's our new who's dude I don't you're
probably gonna tell me like freaking
Betty White dude yeah Betty White
Beetlejuice Joker is like no that's
where I'm at no it's it is bad it's a
Batman we know and love it's everybody's
favorite Batman Dracula it's it's George
Clooney oh it's George Clooney's Batman
dude I remember him it's everybody's
favorite Batman right he's not
everyone's favorite Batman dude what do
you mean are you saying this is the most
Christian Batman movie Batman
it was like the final
the final nail in the coffin for the
fans of like oh you were you had any
hope left and the thing is like they're
not gonna do anything and dude Barry
Allen our superhero our this sh this
character made for children
he when Bruce Wayne is driving up and
George Clooney walks out he says who the
[__] is that and then the movie ends
what
laughs
that's the end of the movie
it what he says who the [__] is that
yeah oh my gosh dude why
freaking effect just evolve right now
it won't even be an artistic use of a
vulgar word we're just gonna throw it in
there no because you get one they saved
it for the end in like a movie and you
get to have even that is
self-referential like I bet they were
counting on people knowing that fact
yeah so cringy it's just it's like this
the writing the movies for the Comic-Con
panels you know like literally it's not
for an audience no you don't hear these
announcements that whole you get one f
word thing is actually not true oh it's
not no you get you get it's the way that
the mpa does it is just by like a group
it's like a review of
parents and people who sign up to do
that and they they say okay this is
going to be
we feel like this is gonna be a PG-13
film
I think maybe it's an old why still but
I have seen a lot of like a lot of
superhero movies have made use of this I
don't know if anybody I don't want to
spoil it but Guardians of the Galaxy 3
one of the best
PG-13 F-bomb drops I've ever really it's
very good so [__] funny and then uh
there's also really fun funny one in um
X-Men first Class remember that one with
uh James McAvoy and and Michael fassman
are they walking into a bar they're like
putting together a team and they find uh
Wolverine
and he's just like [__] off and they
leave and that's the only part with
Wolverine in the movie
so that's super funny but then yeah to
have the like the final beat of the
movie to be flash just basically being
like what the [__] going on here yeah
that's like a perfect metaphor for them
yeah it felt I mean it felt like of all
the movies that I've watched all the
superhero movies that I've watched it
felt the most
um uh corporately driven yeah it felt
like very very transparently a reset of
the universe and like this idea of fan
service like you're feeding birds like
you just oh there's some bird seed in
the bag just throw it on the ground
they'll eat it dude that's why I said
they think we're dumb Birds dude kind of
I felt like I was sitting there I love
this thing and they're just like here's
your slop piggy you know eat it up oh
you're like Christopher Reed tossing
that at me yeah
they'll show pictures of like filet
mignon they're like this is what it
could hear you yeah they're just I mean
that's the movie is they're like showing
you pictures of things that you like
yeah you want some Nicholas Cage there's
no substance in these films and like the
thing is the thing is y'all are guilty
for it because you guys told them they
could do that and they'd make money so
well I hope no they didn't but so so
disappointed and they stopped me guys
real quick like show me show me a
character from the comics don't show me
an actor who almost played a character
they have learned that that is what gets
people to go into theaters it's not
about the story it's not about the
character even it's about the [__]
actor and again these and again these
reveals Jake I can't stress this enough
the the orb fractured he looked out and
saw them and then fixed the problem and
it shut again they did nothing nothing
they interacted not even a little bit
they didn't nothing at all other than be
revealed and then be put away again
revealed don't emote that was it an
emotionless you don't have the moment at
all it was almost like they pulled down
yet from the top shelf they're like
remember this toy okay
[Laughter]
that's enough yeah that's enough okay
to your point I'm sure there's there's a
bunch of fans who were sitting there
like oh whoa
he's like uh
there there was see where it all fell
apart was with Thanos in the first
Avengers movie because Thanos popped up
in the post-credits scene it's it's not
part of the movie it's like a little
little bonus thing for people who stayed
through the credits and everybody went
oh I wonder who that is you know but the
real fans were like oh my gosh Thanos
they're gonna do the infinity Saga and
so everybody went home they went on
Wikipedia they saw the articles that
came out from like you know all the nerd
outlets and they're like oh okay it was
Thanos oh that's cool that's cool
it's like a Grassroots like lore drop
kind of yeah yeah and then it actually
paid off and Ten Years Later he's the
main villain of the movie and now
everybody knows his name oh yeah and
he's a great it's a great character and
that's like the best example of it but
after that they started to go oh you can
just show them you don't even have to do
all that work of like writing
interesting as the character yeah
pop up even the Marvel movies are a guy
even the Marvel movies are really guilty
of this at this point because the Easter
egg it's like the Easter egg industrial
complex where it's like these movies
they know that so much of the press that
comes out about them is going to be like
who showed up completely you know who
did who did you miss you know in this in
the two-hour movie when there was a one
second shot of a guy in a bar you know
and so yeah there's been a ton of Marvel
movies since where they like they'll
name drop a care character or you know a
character will pop up and then be gone
and people are like oh they they'll
you'll hear like some nerd over in the
corner be like oh my God and then you'll
be like oh I gotta look that up later
and then it's this whole like insular
thing that drives these movies and this
is like the this is not only is this
movie like the
apotheosis of like the Multiverse thing
but it's also this thing of like movies
don't have to be movies anymore they're
like no they're like their own they're
just cash cows and you just hey this
director doesn't work [__] your vision I
got my own Vision yeah it's Christopher
Reeves from you know and his dad too
but I can't believe that there is no
vision put a character in from a movie
that got canned at the beginning of the
production yeah just for it just because
yeah honestly
they probably they probably had a list
of characters and they did a survey and
they're like which one is going to get
the most articles written because like
if so for me for me as a direct fan to
buy stuff directing by Google Trends if
they showed let's say they showed like
in the comic books there's like a bunch
of versions of The Flash there's Wally
West and like I grew up with Wally West
in the comics and in the Animated Series
like let's say Wally West is in one of
these things I at least go like oh
that's cool they have like a love and an
admiration for the source material and
maybe other but like people who watch
the movie aren't gonna be like Oh
They'll be like oh what was that but if
it's Nicholas Cage people know that
actor and now it's all yeah like Nick's
saying it's all about it's just actors
now which is so
I mean it's so ugly because it's like
they all the you know it's like these
animated movies where the the cast is
entirely you know famous actors now yeah
where they have the whole press tour is
these people who worked on this movie
for maybe three days and you have this
animation crew of all these insanely
talented people who are like they're
driving the performances that are they
make the suits none of the suits are
even [__] real yeah like it's all VFX
artists doing that work and everything
it's just this
the like a movie can no longer like it
you know now I sound like an old man but
it used to be you walk into the theater
and you're closed off from the rest of
the world and you're having a
unique isolated experience that is like
speaking to some human thing right and
now it's like you walk into the theater
and it's like
it's like you're scrolling through Tick
Tock it's like here's another thing
that's referencing all the other things
that oh you didn't see the you didn't
see Wanda Vision or whatever oh that's
Marvel but like you didn't see the the
show or the the you didn't see the
spin-off you didn't read the spin-off
novel
Supergirl from 1977. here's my fan
Theory Dean now that both Marvel and DC
have multiverses I think it's yeah it's
like 10 years before we see a crossover
not even give it two before they start
dipping into into each other's little
superhero inkwells oh give me money I
think they're actually start starting to
see the fatigue yeah I hope so bro I
hope what it is is really is that the
streaming services are all not working
as well as they thought like Bob Iger
came out and said he's like you really
screwed up with all these Marvel shows
yeah man and it's too much it's so great
though it diluted correct we need to it
it honestly is I said this on the couch
too is it feels like where games are at
too with the pre-order situations yeah
where everybody pre-orders a game that's
a kind of like a known IP and then you
get this buggy disaster and it's like
until people stop voting with their
money in that direction there won't be
any sort of course correction which has
happened has happened DC's last like
four movies have been massive bombs well
this one especially yeah this one lost
almost 200 million dollars which it was
it already did bad for a normal
superhero movie but you you tack on all
the extra [__] like that ending with
George Clooney they shot that four times
with four different sets of actors so
that one of them had Ben Affleck and Gal
Gadot one of them you know it was
probably Michael Keaton and and the
Supergirl actress and then this is the
one they ended on but they had to just
know that
before they shot it yeah look at this
though the flash made just 268.5 million
against a reported 200 million dollar
production budget and 150 million dollar
advertising that was its entire box
office
268. dude you say that like it's a small
amount but but dude they lost almost 200
million dollars negative almost 200
million dollars that is a wake-up call
you just stopped after the first
director walked off they should have
been man maybe this isn't a good idea
yeah weird yeah the rewrite thing always
scares me away personally but it's it is
nice because I I do hope there is some
sort of course correction it doesn't
affect me directly too because I don't
really vote in in those movies Direction
anyway until they're like free to watch
basically it does affect you though
because it takes resources from other
things that could be entertaining you
dude that's valid and that could be
employing artists to actually like work
on on things that can enrich the world
rather than just yeah just steal your
money and then over and over yeah and
that yeah go ahead like
the the worst part for me is that
DC has done such a terrible job with
these characters over the past basically
10 years at this point that
there's really almost unless they just
don't make a DC movie for another 10
years there's really no recovering like
Batman is has had Incredible movies the
last Batman movie was like probably one
of the best if not the best and that
character will continue on
but the rest of this cast of characters
including Superman
have been so forgettable so
yeah it's just like there are such like
there's so many comic books that talk
about like All-Star Superman or even
like the original Flashpoint comic
um like that been deeply meaningful to
me and to see these characters like
trotted out with like 75 years of
history with so many adoring fans to
just be like ah here you go here's our
our fourth director made this movie with
zero heart
um
you know and I don't blame the people
who worked on it they probably did their
best with the situation but it's just um
the the Counterpoint
with a very similar story is the new
spider verse because it's also a
Multiverse film it's also like the main
character has to uh you know adjust to
these new circumstances and like that
movie is
doing a similar thing but it's a pure
work of art it's one of the best movies
that's been made in the last you know
couple years and that's the hopeful
thing for me is that like they're still
still some people treating these
characters with like the reverence I
think they deserve but this one I think
to do that you need to have a you need
to have someone with a vision involved
though yeah and like that's what I see
like a lack of when I go and see
like a Marvel or a DC movie that doesn't
work it's because of lack of vision yeah
and relying on those fan service moments
and like the fan service should be
making a damn good movie about these
characters that the fans love yeah not
just sticking in Easter eggs and like I
do respect do you see actually for that
reason like I think James Gunn's Movie
that that he's made have been really
good like they've been great I've been
like dang these Guardians movies that's
like my one of my favorite superhero
franchises from someone who normally
hates that stuff on the DC side he did
the new he did The Suicide Squad was
awesome
his flavor but like it's because of him
and like in his team and everyone he
works with and you know steers and like
even motivates probably just in being
him to like do really good stuff and it
you it comes through yes also with him
it's like he is really smart and that he
chooses the lesser-known character so
that he has a lot of creative control
because the thing is now he's doing a
Superman movie and I'm actually really
interested to see what he does but like
when he was first starting out in the
scene he chose the Guardians of the
Galaxy because it was like yeah I
remember thinking who the heck he's like
I can do anything with these characters
and I can make them I can have a take
and now a raccoon is having a more
emotional payoff on me than the flash
yeah which is true The Flash look I'll
say this like before I worked at
Corridor I actually edited one feature
okay uh a buddy of mine directed it and
he asked me if I would edit it and I was
like dude of course I've been on my
bucket list the whole time watching a
director from start to finish in the
editorial process try to maintain a
consistent vision for a piece through
all the changes and troubles that arise
put me personally off directing any sort
of feature in the future I don't
personally have that Vision a lot of
incredible directors do but that was
Sans any sort of producer reaching in
and I know that all of these things are
such giant chips that when you bring a
director in and they do have a cohesive
Vision like James Gunn is a great
example to see something through on a
bigger film like flash or Superman or
whatever all those other voices that
slowly just pick it apart they kill your
joke here or they kill the arc here or
they Panic here oh it's their money
their choice they get to do whatever
they want to do they all take a bite and
just completely ruin the meal that
you're preparing before you serve it and
then it's your name on the line and of
course we always come back to it the
visual effects artists online because
they're the last step in the process and
that's why with this whole thing
everyone going the VFX sucked the VFX
suck it's like yes visually not great in
a lot of areas I still hold absolutely
no blame for the visual effects because
I know with this big of a mess as it was
through pre all the way through post
they were probably way overworked deep
into OT unpaid overloaded and there's
like you have a week to do this thing
that takes a month okay uh just get it
done just get it done go go go okay give
it to the people here's your slop yeah
it always starts at the like the like
the baby scene like the idea to do that
like it's like you can't really do that
unless it's all like in an animated film
you can do that but you can't do that in
a in like a
cinematic yeah make it look good make it
done fast make it emotionally you know
appealing and here's this kooky crazy
concept with a couple weeks to work on
it it's like okay well you're not gonna
get anything good
yeah I don't know man I don't know yeah
I mean it's it's never smart to blame
the artist it's about the people making
the decisions that's where this is
coming from they're the ones directing
the movie yeah literally behind like
working from home behind their emails
from their Mansions
actually let's stick in the Nick Cage I
you know my son thinks yeah
that's what it reads as on screen it's
like somebody was like oh put that in
there well and then you get this whole
like there's layers of corporatism where
like nobody wants to take any risks
because you know the the entire
infrastructure and motivational
structure of a corporation is like to
avert risks yeah so anybody who takes a
risk is like really putting their neck
out and so you can never forget
everybody who's in the middle of the
chain somewhere to be like
oh yeah let's take this risk it never
happens it like never happens yeah they
won't even let us touch uh guns in uh
punch for punch because they were
worried about like four extraction two
by the extraction too which is yeah gun
Reliant let's just say that like
literally the entire movie is this is a
like extraction agent hey do you guys
want to make a huge marketing piece for
our movie that's about a bad guys
doing a John Wick scene a John Wick take
without having a firearm in it yeah do
do one for creed but don't do fighting
yeah
I'm thinking it's more like a chess
thing
maybe it's just like montages you know
yeah
um or like the relationship he has with
Rocky Balboa people really don't like
punching right now um yeah people are
just really there's been a lot yeah we
just want to avoid the backlash on X you
know what I mean yeah I'm just
fascinated by the fact that again like
being a very very corporate film in all
aspects it was designed above all else
to reset everything it's like okay we
made a big mess in in a lot of different
areas Clean Slate let's try again and on
the try again it was their biggest flop
so where do you go from there like what
what follows that I there's really no
I don't know that there's any recovering
like I think like what what James gun
gun's plan is to start out with a lot of
The Suicide Squad style projects where
it's like one of them is called Creature
Commandos and you're like who the hell
are they good right it's like it's out
there it's its own thing and he's gonna
do he'll do his Superman movie but
that's not gonna come out for like
probably another three or four years
um Nick Cage in Nick Cage will be
reprising the role because he never did
it maybe this was just a teaser yeah
that's the question everyone wants to
know is is there any hope after all
that's really what this whole podcast
comes down to and I need to hear it from
you for superhero movies I'm whole yeah
I'll hold out hope for James Gunn
because okay I think Warner Brothers is
like an absolute dumpster fire right now
and I mean they got bought by Discovery
right and discovery's already trying to
get rid of them oh whoa they're like
bleeding money by the and they keep yeah
they keep doing this thing it's so sad
that that's what we're like covers
channels staple yeah like uh production
companies of all of Hollywood is now
just a a bleeding ulcer that everyone's
passing around but luckily they just was
Barbie Warner Brothers I think Barbie
was Warner Brothers
Discovery closes acquisition of a T's
Warner media yeah dang man what is that
[Music]
that believe it mean
so they just had the Barbie movie which
did really well it'll like they'll like
limp along well now you know what's
gonna happen with Barbie now Multiverse
they hit up Mattel and they're like
Mattel what do you got Yo Legos let's
get some Legos and Bionicles
let's wrap this out on the on the Mattel
Cinematic Universe we got coming okay
yeah so we got
hot Hot Wheels Hot Wheels all day we got
hot wheels for sure what's the story
there's no story dude it's Hot Wheels
cars you know whatever freaking alphabet
blocks do you remember those that would
be sick the alphabet blocked the movie
oh like the wood blocks that you stack
up but Chris Pratt
here's another Mattel Nick Cage can play
The Wacky letter X yeah yeah oh yeah
he'll be the X yeah oh uh freaking Anna
Taylor Joy would play a great J I think
a great J here we go look at this yeah
we got him on my favorite is they have
hungry hungry
some of these Brands they don't own they
just make toys for us there's a biopic
about the founder of Mattel also
starring uh Ben Affleck are we gonna get
that we always want to know who Mattel
was who was he Mattel is your story yeah
well that's actually I don't know the
New Frontier of Cinema as superhero
movies died is movies about products
superhero movie now is like about it's
like Blackberry Tetris yeah the hot
Flamin Hot Cheetos
and I can freaking tell when he directs
a movie with himself in it and all his
friends he's in flaming hot no
the Nikes
it's a Disney plus original Jake Hulu I
thought you're not trolling me right now
Cinema is strong right now we have
flaming who's at the scene where he
first tastes it it's gonna be off the
charts I watched the trailer because I
love flavorful that's her my favorite
thing in the world yeah and I watched
the trailer it's just like oh I want to
know how they did that and immediately I
was like this is not true no this is
this is just so extreme wait do you know
the story of it was a janitor
this is a [__] this guy this guy who
invented flaming hot Cheetos or
allegedly because he made it up oh he
was a janitor who yeah added spice and
then the CEO I don't know
okay my wife is Mexican she adds hot
sauce to everything okay this isn't some
exceptional thing it's like they add hot
sauce to everything
if every Mexican worked in a chip
company that would be amazing snacks
everywhere
a Cinematic Universe I saw us on
something no but the guy there was an
L.A times Expose and the guy made up the
whole story and this has been like in
the lore for like 20 years that this guy
invented flaming hot Cheetos gosh well
yeah we've gotten the Nintendo Cinematic
Universe on the way after the success of
now they're just the Mario movie we've
got the Frito-Lay Cinematic Universe
Jesus after the success of flaming hot
and then you're gonna have a flaming hot
Hot Wheels merger you're going to start
having those universes Collide and the
Flash will come true man that's like
flash will come true the future that he
talks about in Fight Club where he says
in the future all the galaxies will be
owned by corporations
are Stranger Than Fiction Jake dude zip
Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels about
the guy who invented plastic bags
the big brown bag Mafia was out to get
him oh my God it's a really gritty story
and we're gonna get uh Killian Murphy to
play the bag the first bag yeah the
first bag we have to take it back guys
yeah it's getting out of control can we
end this podcast on a positive note I
don't know yeah Dean with this
negativity Dean where are we headed man
somewhere bright point is in the bright
Direction well I think yeah spider-verse
I think there's this like amazing
Renaissance in animation that is
happening and is coming and I think for
superheroes animation is the best medium
to present these characters like we're
seeing that with spider verse
um because like you know anime like
people love anime and Anime is just like
an adaptation of comic books mangas and
I think in the same vein in the US they
were going to have a big I think where
all these superheroes should go they
should get out of theaters we'll get out
of like you know these big Hollywood
studio movies
and be animated and have like artists
you know have love and care for these
characters and yeah and and maybe maybe
one day and maybe a Bollywood director a
Bollywood director will cross the sea oh
I hope and take the Reigns of a
Hollywood Feed the freedom everyone's
mind let's trade dude I'll go over to
Bollywood they're having fun over there
they're having fun they are not happy
well it's just a reminder it's just a
reminder you can vote with your dollars
that's the beautiful thing we have the
final say and you know Dean maybe the
lesson here is don't go to the premiere
maybe the maybe the lesson here is hang
back get a lay of the land and decide
are these the people you want to give
your money to did they respect the IP
that you love and do they deserve that
hard-earned Dash because the Cheetos
movie is coming out soon so it's already
out oh my God on Disney plus man yeah
baby wait it's on this well what are we
doing guys yes there's a Cheetos movie
too
yeah yeah
right yeah but he's part of the
cinematics when are they going to tie in
Flamin Hot with lemon with lemon though
yeah that's the they do the Cheeto puffs
yeah when are they gonna tie your puffs
okay all right guys that's enough for me
I can't handle any more of this this is
this was neither can I wait for the
ranting everyone yeah let me just ask
this question contemplative uh I need to
take some contemplative time after this
um and I just want to ask one one last
question here Dean do you feel better
getting that off your chest
oh absolutely I've told I've explained
the entire plot of this movie four
different times it takes like 20 25
minutes yeah and each time a little bit
of that trauma is relinquished from my
body so maybe maybe the only thing to do
now everyone who's still listening is to
drop some blessings in the comments for
Dean and his soul give him some peace
yeah just give them a reason to keep
going give us a blessings in the chat
thanks for watching Everybody we're
gonna stop it here this is chaos
oh thank you everyone all right gang
thanks for hearing thank you I feel
better my ramblings oh listen we're
gonna keep at it okay we're gonna keep
at it we're gonna keep trying and don't
give up you know that's all we can do
we're just gonna keep making things keep
running keep running don't stop running
all right
see you later
thank you